Detroit is among the city's worse
affected by the coronavirus Michigan
officials say more than 6,700 people in
Detroit have tested positive and more
than 5% of them have died our national
correspondent Jericka Duncan shows us
the challenges the city faces as advice
as it fights rather this horrible
pandemic it feels unnatural it's a
message of motivation created by a
Detroit based ad company this is not us
sitting out the fight this is us winning
it lifelong Detroiter Valerie Griffin
wants her city to win but says she needs
help to battle the deadly virus while
her part-time job at a laundromat deems
her an essential worker at home she is
lacked running water for several months
which means something as simple as
washing her hands isn't easy how do you
even stay clean are you going to friends
houses to take showers I have like wash
pills Wow
and I fill it up with water and standing
in and I do my thing access to water has
been an issue facing Detroiters since
2014 when the city started a series of
controversial water shutoffs last month
Detroit Mayor Mike Duggan reversed
course through the coronavirus water
restart plan the only residents of
Detroit who should not have water on are
those who don't reach out it's an
essential need to help control the
spread of the virus in a community where
36% of the population lives in poverty
Detroit chief operating officer became
berry this virus is alive it's here and
it doesn't discriminate against anyone
city officials say they're focused on
testing medical workers and volunteers
are testing around 1,000 people per day
Detroiters are resilient and we're
strong and we're proud of where we're
coming from and we will grab ourselves
by the bootstraps
coronavirus has hit Detroit's blossoming
small businesses as well Godwin em2 he
opened up his restaurant in young
village last year it was starting to
look good he says he did his best week
of sales to date at the beginning of
March but profits plummeted after the
city shut down we'll still need to
figure out how to
provide or we'll just have to realistic
we close and then start trying to pay
off all the debt that comes with owning
a business and you say that with a smile
on your face you can see that optimism
across Detroit yes the motor has stopped
here but the people haven't lost their
drive we're coming back with all eight
cylinders because here we don't stop in
the name of fear here we stop in the
name of love
Voyageur iike that campaigned very eery
but very powerful the empty streets they
say are showing that we're winning and
this is what always gets me that we as
human beings are really weapons for
other human beings
there's something very jarring about
that and that we have to stay away from
each other and that's the points that
they're making we really are and I think
that that speaks to what you need to do
the optimism that you see in Detroit we
know that that city has right now nearly
400 deaths just that city alone of
nearly 700,000 residents with the
mayor's confident that those numbers are
starting to sort of plateau but of
course they want to maintain their
vigilance so that people are safe also
even providing transportation to some of
those testing sites so that people who
are struggling to get tested can in fact
find out whether or not they have
coronavirus always boils down to the
testing and behind all of those numbers
are real people I never ever lose sight
of that maybe always remember that
thank you Jericho